isabelle est ce que le théâtre c'est
d'une vocation si la vocation c'est la
certitude sûrement pas j'étais très
attiré par le théâtre mais seulement
dans la lecture des pièces que j'ai pu
faire depuis que je suis au lycée
donc je mis les pieds dans un théâtre à
cette arme
cet art pour quelqu'un qui aurait eu une
vocation très très affirmée une façon
précoce j'ai été au tertre la première
fois 14 me et puis
c'est donc une suite de maillon d'une
chaîne qui s'est formée indépendamment
de la volonté et qui fait que maintenant
je suis aux français c'est à dire que
j'aime auxquels on s'attache parce qu'on
finit toujours en fini moi je commence
par mme attachés aux lieux puis je laime
j'aime la salle j'aime les fauteuils
j'aime les lumières j'aime les
cariatides peut-être chose la scène
j'aime les odeurs qui est sur la scène
j'aime des choses qui sont qui sont très
très proches de moi je suis heureuse moi
je suis dans une troupe
j'ai des rapports formidable parce que
tous les gens avec lesquels je travaille
pour l'instant ce sont des gens que
j'aime que j'admire et je crois que
l'admiration
cet départ de tous les rapports d'amitié
tout les connivences possible